*musique*
*bruits du public*
Qui a pu se blesser en étant sur une chaise? Ewen a réussi. En plein milieu du spectacle à se faire mal au genou.
Qu'est-ce qu'il t'est arrivé?
Ca arrive.
Il s'en fout de ma question.
*rires*
Mais j'ai voulu marquer un panier puis je me suis...
On s'en bat les couilles.
En tout cas bon rétablissement Ewen. Nan j'rigole
chant : "On s'ennuie au maximum"
On s'est mis au pire endroit, on s'est mis devant les toilettes du train qui sentent le caca
On est d'accord ou pas ?
Je ne sais pas. Je ne suis pas restée assez longtemps pour euh ...
Et pour voir, pour entendre ou plutôt pour sentir
Ah! Vous voulez vraiment l'intégralité des sens quoi.
*rires*
Yeh! Luigi babe lourd
Oh non!
Ah y'a une salle de muscu ?
Ouah le truc de ouf y'a tout ce qui faut.
Ooooooh  BRE BRE
Eh je m'entraîne direct...direct frère
Cette barre est collée à l'appareil.
*rires*
Là t'es à 60 kilos    -Impossible
Attend mais c'est soudé
Y'a rien là du tout là   -C'est soudé
*rires*
Allez vas-y. Tire pas trop fort.Tire doucement. Lève toi.
Je sens que je vais larguer une grosse caisse
*rires*
put*** la congestion
Ca c'est la machine pour les moines qui s'entraînent à tirer les cloches
*bruits de cloche*
OUAIS !
*musique* première fois que j'tai vu
je me souviens
j'invente des mots
*rire*
Là c'est euh...
assez importun pour des gens qui ont payés moins cher
ils voient pas le spectacle, ça c'est une bâche
ils ont que le son
*musique*
*rire*
mais vu comment je galère autant marcher quoi
Excusez-moi
Est ce qu'on peut enlever tout les flyers du Woop s'il vous plaît
qui sont sur les sièges
Et les mettre dans une poubelle
De manière à...
... à ce qu'ils ne volent pas mon public
*guitare et chante*
*musique*
*Son d'un film pornographique*
*Bruit de "mouchage"*
*Son du film*
*musique* et Noman ! oh put*** le con!
ah mer** !
*rire*
Attend Norman on voit pas assez bien le placement de produit
voilà
comme ça ?
comme ça c'est bien
ok
merci
*Bruit de foule*
Voix off Norman: Bonjour ! Je suis une luciole !
les cheveux parfaitement nourrient de la racine jusqu'à la pointe
100% Curly
100% Bouclés
à 360°
*rire*
*musique de Mario*
*Musique de Mario*
C'est un ballon dirigeable
Presque nazi
C'est euh...
C'est pas nazi mais
presque
C'est le meilleur kebab de ma vie ! J'adore ! c'est archi bon !
j'vais faire une petite pause pour le spectacle
pendant une durée de mmhh...
j'sais pas le temps que y'en a qui mettrais pour aller au toilettes par exemple
Ba j'vais pas aller aux toilettes mais ce serais la même durée en tout cas
'fin bref à tout de suite merci
Salut !
ça va ?
Ouais et toi ?
t'as un cadeau pour moi ?
ouais
attend on va aller voir ça
attend y'a des vipères là dedans hein
*rires*
J'y vais ou pas ?
j'avoue c'est risqué un peu
*musique épique*
alors c'est quoi le cadeau ?
d'accord...
*rires*
d'accord bah ça fait super plaisir, c'est un très beau collage montage
- Ah ouais tu trouves ?- euh mmh...
hyper mignon
*rire*
qu'est ce qu'il y'a ?
L'homme caca
Ah mon chargeur !
Yes !
mais nan Norman c'est mon chargeur ça
ah non c'est mon chargeur c'est sûr
bah regarde ce qui est écrit dessus
ba ouais y'a écrit Gérard
et alors ?
j'ai pas le droit d'écrire le prénom Gérard sur mes affaires ?
J'ai pas le droit de faire ça ?
J’hallucine incroyable ce mec
incroyable
aucun respect des kiffs des gens quoi
*solo de guitare de norman*
bonsoir
*bruit de la foule*
voilà je suis à l’hôtel, j'ai dormi cette nuit
Heu... combien de temps ?
0 secondes, 0 secondes
j'ai fait une grosse nuit blanche, et ce soir je dois jouer
devant ... 3200 personnes à Rennes ... Voilà
Il y a beaucoup de pression, de stress, d'angoisse, de fatigue
quand on prépare ça, plein fois avant de monter sur scène
Je me dis: "Est ce que je vais y arriver ? Est-ce que je vais assurer? "
j’espère qu'il n'y a pas un moment donné où je vais faire ...
"Attendez, je vais tomber dans les pommes, bonsoir "
*Musique*
*Cri de foule*
He on fait des photos direct !
*Rires*
*Musique*
Maintenant je vais dire une phrase à la con, que toute ma jeunesse j'ai entendu dans des émissions à la télé
et qu’aujourd’hui je pense vraiment parce qu'elle est vraie
même si t'es au bout de ta vie physiquement et mentalement
Quand tu vois 5000 personnes se déplacer pour toi
Rire, se lever; t'applaudir
ça te donne un courage, mon gars et une force qui te rend imbattable
*Musique*